very excited to have you here today. So,
Avil is an assistant professor in the
computer science and machine learning
departments at Carnegie Melon University
uh and also a researcher at Google
DeepMind where he works on reinforcement
learning uh for uh Gemini foundation
models. uh he finished his PhD uh at UC
Berkeley uh advised by Sergey Levvin in
uh 2023
and uh he's also most famous for
creating the the CQL reinforcement
learning algorithm. Uh his lab at CMU um
the AI and reinforcement learning lab is
interested in a broad range of topics
ranging from core reinforcement learning
algorithms to scaling or rail methods to
foundation models to real robots. Uh and
with that uh let's give a big applause
for Avil.
[applause]
>> Thanks for the introduction and thanks
for for having me. Um yeah, it's uh it's
nice to see that there's a class on
robot learning which is just so many
guest lectures in in in the class. Um I
I looked up the schedule so that's quite
nice to to see. Um okay, so today uh
I'll talk a little bit about some of the
work we've been doing in my lab at CMU
on on sort of um things involving robot
learning. um but kind of thinking about
this problem from um pro perhaps a
slightly different angle to what people
think about this right now. So there's
you you probably know there's a lot of
work on like how on scaling data scaling
models and robot learning and so on. But
uh in my lab we work a lot on LLMs as
well. So we work on like LLMs, we work
on fundamental RL algorithms and so on.
And like I do feel like there's like a
lot of missing pieces from the LLM
recipe that we haven't figured out in
robot learning or that have no analog in
robot learning right now. So I figured
I'll talk about some such work that we
we have done which kind of tries to
address this gap. So if you wanted to
actually take uh the recipe of from NLP
from vision of of scaling models and and
data then what should you be doing um
for robots differently? Uh that's going
to be basically this talk. Um and I'm
going to cover things sort of at a
higher level than going into too much
detail into any work that I'll talk
about. Uh but the links to the papers
are up there. So if you have any
questions you can definitely check them
out as well. Um okay so let's get
started. So u the broad question which
this talk starts with is you know can we
replicate the LLM recipe for robots? And
to answer this question right the the
obvious thing to first ask is like well
what's the recipe for LLMs that we have
seen work really well. So at a high
level like what most people think um
makes LLM LLM work well is training on
diverse data from the internet. sort of
like diverse text data. You kind of get
a model out of it and then you would
post train or fine-tune this model on
top of a limited uh data set uh that
exists out there for your particular
task. So you post train this general LM
to follow instructions. You post train
this general LM to solve hard math
problems. You find you you postrain it
to sort of do really good things on the
web etc etc. Uh in the robot land this
recipe has resulted in the following
sort of kind of analogies uh from from
all these places. So in robot land if
you see what uh today's sort of uh fully
datadriven recipes look like they look
like training uh what's called a VA
policy vision language action policy uh
on top of a bunch of diverse robot data
and that's what's called pre-training
and then you would potentially fine-tune
this policy uh with some task specific
data limited number of task specific
demonstrations uh for post- training so
that's what this looks like that's what
the current instantiation of this of
this protocol in the case of robots
Now, if you look at it this way, you
know, on the surface, it all looks
great, but there's actually a lot of
nuances that we missed out on when we
instantiated the LLM recipe for robots.
So, I'm going to go into that in one by
one. So, the first thing um that you
know we we look at here is the fact that
actually for LLMs as well, the recipe is
a bit more nuanced. Um and and this
nuance is coming up a lot more clearly
these days when you see reasoning
models. So, what is the recipe? The
recipe looks like pre-training on some
large text corpora as usual. But rather
than going right away from pre-training
to post- training, you would end up
having the space of of what's called
mid-training. Uh so you see all these
LLMs have uh sort of these long chains
of thought which you know are basically
the kinds of pieces of text that you
don't ever see on the internet but you
imbue into the model from a using a
phase that's called mid-training in the
middle of pre-training and post-
training. So you would end up running
pre-training. You'll end up then imbuing
the model with some uh amount of
behaviors that probably are useful for
problem solving downstream which is
called mid-training. Uh and it's usually
useful for like teaching the the model
how to search through different
potential solutions for a given prompt
that you asked it. And after this
process you'll end up running post-
training. And this post training is also
run via reinforcement learning or R. In
the robot land there's no analog for
this mid-training phase. Also the post-
training phase right now is being done
with pure fine-tuning on human
demonstration data. Um beyond that
you'll also be surprised that
pre-training right now in my opinion uh
the way we do it for robots is kind of
not quite correct. Um and I'll not be
talking about that. But today's talk
I'll talk about mid-training and post-
training a little bit more in detail. So
just to sort of go into this a little
bit more more more more concretely
typically the goal of pre-training in
the context of language has been to
learn from arbitrary data on the
internet. It's almost like I'm learning
what it means to generate text on the
internet. And this model is not
technically representing what's what you
can think of as an optimal policy or an
optimal uh distribution over over next
tokens condition on the prefix. Um but
however in the case of robots actually
if you look at what pre-training looks
like it usually looks like training uh
the the robot to solve multiple possible
tasks multiple possible language
instructions specify those tasks uh
solve those multiple possible tasks uh
in an optimal manner because all the
data that we use for robots is an expert
data set and this in the LLM context
looks a lot more like what's called
instruction fine-tuning or it's a part
of post- training as opposed to
pre-training. So this already sort of is
very different for robots than for LLMs
and there's a question mark as to
whether the the the robot recipe can
even work here. Um I have some thoughts
on that and some of the work that's
ongoing in my lab actually touches upon
this question. I'll not be talking about
this part a lot but what I talk about is
the second two parts today uh in this
talk. So the second part uh in mid
training as I mentioned earlier um the
goal of mid-training for LLMs is to
imbue them with certain behaviors or
skills that can help you improve
autonomously during post training. Um so
this is often referred to as the phase
of improving exploration for robot uh
for for for language but there's no such
phase for robots and likewise the post-
training part uh for LLMs is done by
autonomous rollouts. So you let an LLM
uh tackle a particular prompt or a
problem autonomously. you often make
simulators for this process and uh or
and or or you just deploy an LM in the
real world and you now learn from the
feedback that you get in this case. So
you kind of like learn to learn useful
behaviors by actually interacting with
the target environment that you care
about. So what I'm going to do today uh
you know is talk a little bit about what
would this mid-training and post
training look like for robots um in this
in in this particular you know if you
believe in this particular framing of
the high level paradigm of how we train
these models. So I'll talk a little bit
about some work that we did on what you
can call um mid training for robots. Um
so it's uh this idea of like actually
collecting data a bit differently so
that you imbue the model with
interesting skills or behaviors such
that when you deploy the policy on the
robot it can do really well. Um and when
you do this you actually see a lot of
benefits of of mid-training that we see
in language models. So if you if you're
familiar with this idea of test time
scaling or thinking for longer you kind
of see something similar for for robots
when you when you do this. uh and you
also get like a lot more data efficiency
and a lot better generalization which
are exactly the things that mid-training
gives uh to you in in the language land.
So I'll talk about that a bit and then
I'll talk a little bit about how can you
do post- training for robots in a in a
uh in an efficient manner and here we'll
talk about how you can deploy
offthe-shelf generalist robot policies
on a real robot and let them learn from
their autonomous data. So we had this
algorithm that's called policy agnostic
RL which is a very simple method um
which can help you like just improve
your um your your pre-trained robot
policy uh online uh in a sample
efficient manner and we did get some one
of the first results for fine-tuning of
these general VAS in the real world
using this work. So that's the sort of
the rough outline for for today's talk.
Um okay so let's start with this idea of
mid training. Um and uh I'm going to
talk a little bit about what exactly I
mean by recovery and correction data
that you see up here. If you're
interested in the paper, the the paper
um sort of citation is listed here. You
can you can just search it up on archive
and you you'll find it. Cool. Okay. So
currently, as I mentioned a couple of
times already, the current robot data
collection protocol for training all of
these large generalist policies has been
to basically just ask humans to tell you
operate the robot to show expert
demonstrations on solving some tasks and
you just like collect tons of data like
this. So for instance, like this is a
particular task from the Aloha Unleashed
paper where they had this bmanual arm
trying to like close Ziploc bags uh and
and you kind of had to like put stuff
inside of it and close the lid together.
Um another task that we particularly
look at in our work is um I guess you
know this video will will come to it is
this task from like of shirt handling
where a human teleoperator here it's my
student Jan he's like actually
teleyoperating this bmanual setup to
basically insert this hanger into a
t-shirt. So that's one of the tasks we
consider in in our work and here it's
all fully teleyoperated. So this is just
a demo that you would collect and you
would train your policy on top of this
sort of a demo um uh to just imitate all
the actions that you see up here. Um so
that's the that's the kind of current
robot data collection protocol. Now this
data collection protocol is pretty good
but the problem here is that it's it's
actually suboptimal for generalization.
So if you think about uh the analogy
between this data collection protocol
and LLMs you can think of this as of
like expert data collection as just
showing to you what the optimal solution
for a given math problem is. However, if
you wanted to generalize, if you want
your robot to be robust enough to deal
with different t-shirts with potentially
different uh different uh sort of
orientations of things with potentially
its own failures that it might encounter
when it goes and solves the task, you
need the you need the policy to learn
how to kind of recover from these
behaviors and that notion of recovery we
also see in LLMs like we see LLMs not
directly get to an answer for a given
question but all these reasoning models
actually go and explore and search
through different branches of solutions.
to then come up with the right answer.
And that's kind of the same thing that
we do here. So we basically collect a
lot of counterfactual data in some ways
through this process of human
interventions that scales uh recoveries
and corrections. So I'll just show you a
um you know show you a video. So what we
do is we train a base policy on some
expert demonstrations and now we deploy
this base policy and collect some amount
of recovery and correction data
according to a particular protocol that
we describe in this work and the idea is
this recovery and correction data can be
thought of as backtracking and and
self-correction style data for LLMs and
if you train the policy on top of this
data it'll learn to be more robust to
the particular target task. So just to
show you an example uh let me play this
video. Um so here right now if you see
there's it's an autonomous policy that
is trained on some limited amount of um
like uh like demonstration data. So it's
a pre-trained autonomous policy. Uh you
can already see it's a bit slow and it's
not as fluid as or not not as flexible
as what humans would do and it tries to
sort of solve the task but then you'll
see that it puts the hanger in front of
the t-shirt and now the human takes
over. Um they potentially intervene
here. they show um what the correction
should be and terminate the intervention
and just having this notion of like uh
of like you know recovering from the out
of distribution state that the policy
was going towards. Let me just bring it
back here. Um so just oh oops yeah so
just recovering from the state from
which uh the policy was making a mistake
at so it's the state at which the hanger
is in front of the t-shirt recovering
from it and showing the correct rule uh
which is recovering back and showing the
correct thing is good enough uh for
showing you how to backtrack. So what we
do in this work is we collect a lot of
this kind of data and we train on top of
this data uh for this mid-training
phase. So we have a pre-trained policy
learned by imitation learning. We do mid
training on top of this kind of recovery
and correction style data. So just to
show you uh sort of some some uh kind of
illustration for what this is
schematically doing and and what the
main insight is. The main insight for
enabling this thing to work is the fact
that recovery u is actually easier than
correctly solving the task for many
tasks we care about. And the same thing
is true for language models as well. So
if you think about it, here's a
schematic cartoon of a long horizon task
like t-shirt hangar insertion where you
started off with an initial state. The
initial state can be anywhere across the
scene. So it's a larger larger uh area
disk here. And now as you solve a task,
you're kind of slowly narrowing down
this the volume of states you're you're
going to you're going to visit. So this
cone or the cone like or a funnel like
shape basically tells you that you are
kind of narrowing down the set of good
states that your demos might possess.
And here are potential subtasks. So
subtask could mean grabbing a hanger
from the from the shelf potentially
inserting one side of the collar and the
hanger potentially inserting the other
side of the collar hanger and so on. So
these are potential subtasks inside of
this particular task. So what we talk
about here is the fact that in general
if your policy might end up going away
from your good demonstration data like
in this black line, you would want the
the human to show you how to recover
back to the indistribution manifold
inside of this funnel and then correctly
solve the task from there on. And here
if recovering is easier because you're
recovering to sort of a broader set of
states then you can easily learn this
recovery behavior uh from data that you
collect from limited data that you have
because it's a easy tole learn behavior
in a way. So once you do this the policy
now when you train the policy and you
deploy it the policy might end up
recovering a lot correcting itself a lot
and eventually we'll end up solving the
task a lot better. So the idea is to
scale up these notions of recovery and
correction.
If you're more mathematically inclined,
here is like a simple sort of model
which we discussed in the paper and I'm
not going to talk about it too much
today because there I don't have too
much time to talk about it. But if
you're interested in the math here, you
can actually do some very simple math to
explain why this thing works. So I like
to call this idea the the P to the K
model. So the idea is the same. Let's
say the robot attempts to complete a
particular subtask with probability and
it succeeds with probability P. then in
the probability with with which it fails
meaning 1 minus P if it can recover to a
particular indistribution point um then
you can potentially get the the robot to
the ability to try again and trying
again will now gives you uh trying again
will give you the ability to reduce your
compounding errors over a whole roll out
so think of it as if your LLM or if the
LLM analogy makes more sense to you
think of it as your if your LLM goes and
tries to attack a certain problem with a
certain solution ution approach and it
fails, it can go back and try something
else and in in effect you're kind of
reducing the total errors that you might
get as opposed to just like cloning the
correct answer where if you failed you
would just like never recover at all. So
this is a simple way to kind of amplify
your model's uh ability to solve long
horizon tasks by exploring in the right
way by by recovering at the right times
by continuing at the right times and so
on and that's sort of the main main idea
of this method. Uh and this also gives
us data that covers some of the unseen
regions of the state space and that's a
good thing as well because it gives you
coverage over behaviors that the policy
might encounter but human teleoperators
will never encounter.
Okay. So um so just to sort of show you
some more uh results here. Um so another
thing that we find here is because of
this recovery and retry behavior you
kind of get something that is equivalent
to test time scaling uh for for robots.
So in in in typical language modeling
test time scaling is usually referred to
the process of using longer chains of
thought for thinking for longer. So a
lot of these open AI 01 03 models and
basically at this point every single LLM
is a thinking LLM where it would go and
do a lot of computation before it spits
out an answer for you. In this way, in
the case of robots, this approach of
like scaling recovery and correction
data for mid training kind of gives you
this ability to uh to kind of do
something similar but not in some
language space or not in some thought
space but rather at a low-level action
space. So you're basically um um you're
you're you're basically showing the
policy um some ability to sort of like
just do multiple actions over time to
succeed better on the particular task.
So as a result for it what we found was
that our particular approach which is
rack it used a simple flow matching
transformer policy which is not too big
but on within just 5 hours of data
collection um you know where we scaled
up like this recovery and correction
style data we could get a very good
success rate u which is comparable to
sort of the the best prize result on
such a task of shirt hanging from Aloha
unleashed where they had a smaller
policy but then they had way more data
um like they had 89 hours of data for
for training And this was just pure
expert data. We didn't have that much
data at all. It's like way more
efficient like an order of magn more
efficient overall. And also compared to
sort of this result from bite dance
where they had a 4B vision language
action model like a lot of pre-training
and so on they also still used a lot
more data but again got a much lower
success rate than ours. So it's a lot
more data efficient and parameter
efficient which is precisely what you
see uh with LLMs which can reason as
well uh in a similar manner. And to just
show you some uh examples here, what we
found was that again as you so if you
remember if if you're familiar with sort
of the the OpenAI uh blog post on the
when the 01 model came out in 20 2024,
they had this plot which showed that
performance improves as a function of
your uh of your COT length or or of your
test time compute is what they say. We
had a similar plot that we could draw
for robots now where the x-axis is the
number of recoveries your policy does
within the course of a rollout when it's
deployed and the y-axis is success rate
which again you see there's a linear uh
linear fit uh on top of it. So it's
quite intriguing that you can kind of
draw similar analogies from like coot
length and and and RL in in and language
models the sort of robot learning
policies and and again um sort of like
but here the the length of a coot is
replaced by number of recoveries in an
episode that you that you run. So that's
sort of the the main result here. Um so
let me show you some some quick
examples. So like um the first policy up
top here. So these are these are three
uh this is a video. I'll I'll play this
video in a second. This is uh these are
three different types of policies that
we compare. So first one is the rack
policy or this recovery and correction
style policy trained on recovery and
correction style data. Uh the second one
is this edgy dagger policy. So it's a
it's a it's an approach for doing human
interventions uh within the rollout but
again it's not uh structured in the form
of recovery and correction. So there's
no backtracking and correction. It just
shows you, it just lets the human
intervene whenever and the full demos is
just like expert data training a BC
policy on top of it. And the three
columns that you see here are like three
different camera views. So for the left
gripper, the right gripper and the the
third person camera view here. So you'll
see that the rack policy ends up making
many retries and corrections until it
succeeds. Uh the edgit tagger policy
will end up making some sort of
corrective attempts because it's trained
on some kind of intervention data but
doesn't quite generalize. And you'll see
that the BC policy just is you know just
fails overall. So I'll just play this
video here and you can see all the three
different um different policies acting.
So they are kind of trying to solve the
same sort of task um putting the hanger
inside of this t-shirt. Um and you'll
see that they um and all at 1x speed. So
nothing uh nothing nothing more than
that. So you'll see that this uh policy
ends up um generalizing a lot better and
some annotations will come up as well um
here. So um so the first side is
probably okay for uh for most policies.
So if you see the rack policy ends up
retrying itself uh because it did the
thing incorrectly
um and you'll see it it eventually
succeeds. So it can it is persistent in
a way um and and that's a good thing.
And the BC policy on the other hand the
lowest row actually just gets stuck uh
overall
um
yeah uh and then it doesn't know how to
succeed. Whereas the rack policy
whenever it starts to get into this like
weird scenario because of this recovery
and connection data it would like learn
to like kind of go back and retry and
that's like a like a good thing overall.
So the the the edg policy just failed
and the imitation learning policy also
just failed overall and this is not a
cherrypicked example this we see many of
these uh in our in our work. So actually
I was going to if I had more time I
would have shown you uh a few more
videos but the website for this paper
has a lot of videos on it um including
many other tasks which again have this
notion of like multiple possible like
sort of fairly long horizon tasks that
would require otherwise a lot of data
for training. That's kind of the general
flavor of tasks we study here. And in
all of these cases we again find that
the recovery and collection style
behaviors actually help you a lot uh
overall. So I just had this slide on
looking at some videos but uh maybe in
the interest of time I'll u I'll skip
this but I I can come back to it uh once
I I finish quickly uh after this. Uh
cool. Okay. The second thing I wanted to
just very quickly mention because I
probably just have two three minutes so
is this work on post training uh with
policy agnostic RL. Um it's uh a paper
that was run by my student Max um here
at CMU. And the idea was kind of
something basically about just very
standard motivation around post training
that you know we'll want to ultimately
um take these generalist policies and
then fine-tune them very quickly on a on
a on a real robot uh with real world
interaction. And currently there's not a
lot of work that tries to do this at
scale with general policies. Like
there's a lot of work including my own
work from my PhD days which tries to do
this for like single task policies but
not for generalist policies at all. So
the problem now with generalist policies
is that a lot of the RL machinery that
we have built over the last few years
has it really stably only works with
like gshian policies which have fewer
parameters and this is actually even
true to this state like there's a lot of
work on on doing the RL with flow
matching policies RL with diffusion
policies but a lot of that work actually
is quite unstable if you actually run it
on a robot. uh this work is a bit old so
this is from like a year ago so back
then none of those things even existed
but even to this day a lot of the work
that has come out on fine-tuning general
policies tends to be quite quite fragile
overall so what we wanted to do in this
work was to improve uh any general
policy class um including diffusion
policies maybe transformer policies flow
matching policies etc and build a stable
recipe for doing so uh overall um so
what we found was actually the fact that
if you if If you go and ask the question
of why is fine-tuning offthe-shelf
policies hard, you'll realize that a lot
of the times when you do RL, you care
about improving some notion of a value
function
uh on top of uh actions that were coming
from your policy. So you kind of want to
train the policy to maximize this value
function or Q function in some way or
the other. In some ways this kind of a
objective requires computing the
gradient of the policy of the policies
predictions with respect to its own
parameters.
So grad five of pi of s uh is what you
kind of care about computing. Uh
computing this is actually quite
problematic for basically many policies.
So it's problematic for diffusion
policies because you could go through
that propagate through the diffusion
process. For flow matching policies, the
same thing for transformers, you cannot
even compute this because often times
the action is sampled. So there's no
differentiable connection altogether. So
you have to rely on reinforce style
objectives to do so. So this is
something that is quite hard for this is
a very different very hard reward loss
function for the policy to maximize. So
what we did do in this work or the main
idea in this work was to sort of go and
and try to decompose the policy
improvement process into two steps. Um
the first step was to just run this
gradient process on top of action
particles themselves. So rather than
updating the policies parameters with
respect to the gradient of maximizing
the Q function, we just find how to
modify the action vector itself if I
wanted to maximize the Q value. So I
call that the optimized actions. And the
second step was to distill these
optimized actions back to your policy
using a standard maximum likelihood
style loss. And that loss seems to work
because most of the models out there
most of the generative models or most of
machine learning models out there are
just trained to uh train with maximum
likelihood. So distilling some notion of
actions into a particular model is just
nothing but maximizing likelihood which
should be easy which should be possible
at least for most policies out there. So
all we do is we we we take so the actual
algorithm is a bit more complicated but
we take the base policy produce
different actions run some sort of
optimization nonparametrically on those
actions and then just distill those or
behavior clone those actions uh into the
base policy and this allows us to be
agnostic to the policy because all of
the optimization or all of the RL is
happening on actions and not on the
policy itself.
>> Mhm. So this is sort of a very simple
idea that actually has been around for
some time. But the nice thing in that we
realized in this work was that the very
same simple instantiation of
hyperparameters, algorithm design
choices, etc. that we did for one
possible policy class actually works
well for other policy classes as well
for different uh algorithms for online
fine-tuning or online learning of the of
the policy. So just one uh kind of
interesting result and I'll stop after
this was that we kind of got some very
good results on uh on fine-tuning open
VA. So this work was done like a year
ago at this point. We are working on a
on a version of this with like more
modern policies and more modern value
functions right now in our lab. But this
work was done a year ago where tasks
were still very simple. But then this
was the first result I know where we
could fine-tune you know the the
state-of-the-art PLA model at that time
which is open VLA without needing any
kind of demonstrations just autonomously
on the fly on a real robot and this was
done in 40 minutes only and that was
quite good because uh 40 minutes of
online is quite easy with like a
terrible robot like a widow X on here
that you see now robots are obviously
much better and also like VAS are much
better so this number can be probably
reduced down to 10 minutes uh if you use
the right approach so that sort of quite
quite intriguing and we also had some
results on single task policies uh which
were slightly different from so open was
a transformer policy this is this is
diffusion policy so again the same
approach uh sort of works for both of
these classes of methods with the same
hyperparameters so it's a very simple
idea that works really well uh when you
go to scale uh these policies um so yeah
that's sort of this approach um that's
basically what I had so the main
takeaway if you want uh to take away
from this talk should be that we should
think about we should think very
carefully about how can we how we take
these generalist model training recipes
and instantiate them for robots
pre-training is still a big open
question uh in my mind uh I don't think
we are doing pre-training correctly
right now but mid-training uh meaning
data scaling in the right way and
fine-tuning or post- trainining in the
right way both can take you a long way
so thinking about what learning lessons
can be transferred from one to the other
can be quite helpful here uh yeah and
I'll stop there I'll yeah happy to take
any questions u thanks Thanks for
listening to my very uh rushed true
talk. Uh [applause]
thanks for the amazing talk. Um any
questions from the audience?
Yes, I have one question here.
>> Can you hear me? Yeah. Um thank you for
for a good talk. Um two questions. The
first one is you you mentioned a couple
of times um that you have used that the
current pre-training landscape for
robotic foundation models uh isn't where
it needs to be. Can you maybe elaborate
on that at the high level uh and maybe
point us towards some some works from
your lab that that propose an
alternative or or improved solution for
those. Um and then if I if I can ask a
second question um could you quickly
elaborate on um again on on the
differences in interventions between
your work in the mid training um versus
a method like HG dagger and and repeat
again why these led to to your superior
results.
>> Yeah, that's a good question. So let me
go into the edg dagger question first.
Um yeah, I think I I didn't have time to
really cover this much in much detail,
but I can show you some um so yeah, I
think this picture probably makes uh the
easiest sense. So if you can can you see
my m mouse pointer actually or um no uh
>> is my mouse pointer visible on the
screen? Um
>> or maybe
>> he doesn't know the answer.
>> Yes. Yes, we can see it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Um yeah. So I
guess maybe Oh, okay. Great. So I can
also draw on the screen. That's nice.
Okay. So all I was saying was so here
you see like you know the the our
approach kind of you know when once the
policy is outside it you kind of recover
and then you go and connect. So you are
kind of going back and correcting
itself. Edg dagger would just take you
from this state and like would just go
and solve the task right away. Um I
think that's sort of the the the typical
notion of the of the phrase edgy dagger.
Now I would also say that edgy dagger
the way it's been described in
literature doesn't actually mention
precisely a very concrete recipe for how
humans should intervene. But the typical
notion has been well if you're going
slightly out of distribution you should
just like solve the task from right
there. But what we do here is we kind of
go back and try to solve the task from
there on. So for example if you were um
uh oh okay so if you were uh let me just
go back here somewhere. Okay. So uh
basically the idea here would be uh if
you're if you're uh if you're if you're
starting to make a mistake uh what edg
would try to do is would just try to
directly like if you're starting to make
a mistake it'll just try try to directly
go in uh directly insert the hanger into
the t-shirt whereas what we want to do
is we want to kind of go back to a
previous state uh which is quite subtle
here but actually very visible in other
demonstrations where look like you know
rather than going directly into the
t-shirt from here on we would kind of go
and move the robot arm quite away from
on the t-shirt and then try to insert it
from there on. So basically this notion
of recovery not being present in a g
dagger is the big issue uh overall.
That's the the main difference. I think
some of the other tasks that we have
actually show this example quite quite
better uh overall um uh in uh on on the
website but recovery not being present
is the main thing. Uh and that gives you
the gains because now if you just try to
correct yourself uh then you might not
know how to correct yourself right away
but recovery is kind of strictly easier.
Um so that's the main gap that that
comes in. Um the other the the other
question I think for pre-training we
don't have a work out yet. We want to
put something out in the next one or two
months. But the rough idea being that I
think that like when you think about LLM
pre-training we think about just
modeling the distribution of all
possible text. We don't train blas on
possible actions that a robot could ever
take. We just train it on the narrow
slice of actions that are quote unquote
optimal or expert like because human
teleoperators show them that. So maybe
we should rethink what uh like really a
a BLA policy should model when you when
you train it uh with during pre-training
or what kind of data should you be
training it on. It shouldn't be like
expert data or just modeling one mode of
behavior. Maybe it should be multiple
modes of behavior because that's what an
LM models. But again this is sort of the
rough intuition. We still have something
in flight on that. I don't think that
much of the community has been thinking
about this but that's the graph
inclusion. Um,
>> hey, I have
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> yeah. Yeah, please go ahead. Yeah,
>> sorry. Um, I have another quick
question. You mentioned that it performs
better than a dagger, and I'm just
wondering why like is it because it
learns the recovery method itself when
um the action goes out of distribution
like off like off policy intervention.
And you mentioned back propagation like
how exactly does it actually learn the
recovery behavior from like you helping
it like push it back to a previous state
like uh like as opposed to dagger.
>> Yeah. So basically the the the rough
thing is like it learns this recovery
behavior. So it learns to recover as
opposed to just like going back um going
going to like trying to like solve a
task from from some place that it has
already reached. So it does learn the
recovery behavior. And the second
question I think I missed uh what the
second part was
>> um why exactly does this like you
mentioned back propagation at some point
like how exactly does is this better
than basically learning how to um get to
another state that like from like why
exactly is the recovery behavior better
than just like directly um finding uh
like a policy that reaches a further
state directly
>> from a good question. I think the the
reason why that happens is because the
volume of states that you can recover to
is often a lot higher for most natural
robotic tasks than the volume of states
that uh that you see in the see from
from there on. So imagine this like for
example like if a uh so I guess you can
actually show to this theoretically as
well. So if you let's say go to an OD
state uh trying to come back to the
manifold of the of good states which is
shown by this funnel is actually harder
because there's very few states from
there on that are still valid states for
the task. But going back is sort of
easier because there's many more states
that you can go back to and you can
continue from there on. So if you think
about like uh like trying to imitate
data which shows you how to correct
yourself eventually you have a narrow
space of states that you need to somehow
hit. So any mistakes in the correction
in in mimicking the correction part
would be problematic for you. Whereas if
you just need to learn how to recover,
if there's many very many very many many
many states from which you to which you
can recover uh because you're going
backwards in the task, you can actually
like restart uh from there on and
succeed uh a lot better because there's
many more states that you can go back to
which are within your like uh good demo
states uh in this particular setting. So
it's just a volume argument roughly. uh
overall
>> uh can you explain a little more about
how the local and global optimization
part works in the fine-tuning for
robots?
>> Yes. Uh I can talk about that. I also
unfortunately had to run. So maybe let's
make this the last question and then I
can I'm happy to always answer any
questions over email or if you have any
thoughts just feel free to email me. Uh
unfortunately just had like a lot of uh
I I have to go to somebody's false exams
actually so I just want to not be super
late to that. But um but yeah, I I think
the rough idea for global optimization
is you would just sample n different
actions and you would now take uh
compute arg max over the q function over
those actions and filter the ones that
attain high enough q values. So let's
say you have n uh I guess here you have
k actions you would retain m actions
that have the highest q value and then
local optimization is just take a
gradient step on that action with
respect to the q function. So you want a
to move in the direction that maximizes
Q of SA and you do this via gradient
descent. That's the simple approach.
>> Cool. Uh thank you so much I let's let's
thank again for speak for just making it
super uh tough in between things
[applause] but yeah
>> see you soon.
>> Yeah. See you. Bye.